let's go here's something interesting
Joshua who called in a few months ago to
talk about memes is holding on and he's
been holding on for a while Joshua
what's going on today uh my connection
is really bad I just want to say that I
love the show and you should definitely
check out the debate between CJ and
Peterson because different got btfo yeah
the half-hour I saw you know here's my
thing about it so I watched a half-hour
of the Peterson Dziedzic debate and then
I talked to my dad and brother who
watched the entire thing and then I read
a couple of analyses or it's oh I still
have to watch the whole thing to see if
I agree with this assessment but the
consensus from everything I've read and
everyone I've spoken to so far is that
what was billed as this debate of the
century with two intellectual
juggernauts ended up being very
anticlimactic with really no and it
doesn't matter if they agreed on a lot
of stuff it's fine to agree nothing
notable or new coming from it that we
can now take and say hey here's an idea
that we can consider that that's that
that's what most of most of the analyses
I've read so far in people I've spoken
to say that it just kind of fell flat
but I have to watch the whole thing to
fully form my opinion I just wanna
mention something Peterson did bring up
something he said that she said to
create his own movement or people should
start their own movement
okay Joshua thank you so much appreciate
the phone call we will take a quick
break if you're holding on please don't
hang up because I will go back to the
phones if you're holding don't hang up
quick break right back after this